les affiches tel que convenu michel
parent est prêt lundi il attend 150
travailleurs sur deux chantiers majeurs
par terre on a mis des lignes pour que
chaque travailleur respecte la
distanciation avant leur enregistrement
pour avoir accès au chantier les
travailleurs vont devoir franchir une
sorte de douane pour déclarer leur état
de santé
chaque matin chaque travailleur qui vont
entrer sur le chantier voix accueillis
par laurent de prévention et puis
doivent répondre à ce questionnaire l'or
et surtout bien le signe tout est pensé
pour respecter les consignes et on a
installé quatre stations de lavage avant
de commencer les ouvrages le lavage des
mains sera aussi obligatoire
on a aussi un autre travailleur qu'on a
embauché à temps plein as maintenant
juste pour faire la désinfection de
chance on n'est pas encore sûr de
comment on re perte de productivité mais
ça va coûter quelques centaines de
milliers de dollars mais tiff faut
s'habituer luc antoine boivin va
superviser la reprise de quatre
chantiers de maisons de ville
lui aussi il a ajusté ses méthodes pire
assure également qu'elle joue le
désinfectant pour l'outillage ce que
s'assurer la trompe uv reese un nouveau
type cas précis on les nettoie comme il
faut pour la prochaine journée
travaillent dans les salles de repos on
ne prend pas de risque non plus deux
travailleurs par table assis à chaque
bout pourrait aider aussi à changer les
habitudes on a même mis le nom de chacun
des travailleurs ale place attitrée pour
s'assurer qu'elles respectent les
mesures mises en place une nouveauté
sera aussi installée sur les casques
tout le monde doit avoir la vision lundi
matin on adapte les casques de tous nous
de tous nos travailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs l'idée d'un au travail alors
ce qu'on va avoir des situations où est
ce qu'on va travailler à proximité
exemple dans la manutention de portes et
fenêtres si ces chantiers entendent
respecter les normes à la lettre les
syndicats ont quand même des craintes
des chantiers soit extraordinaire toutes
les mesures mises de l'avant par la
santé publique vos ennemis mais il ya
toujours des récalcitrants seront qu'une
font pas qu'ils veulent rien faire qui
pensent que c'est pas grave comme on va
au travail
lundi ce sera le jour de vérité 400
inspecteurs de la csst vont être sur le
terrain pour s'assurer de la sécurité de
tous ici pierre alexandre bolduc radio
canada québec